prepare yourselves i'm about to defend
crypto
look last week tonight bill maher did a
segment on cryptocurrency which was
so bad so embarrassing and
simultaneously
so smug that not only do i have to
address the problems here i also
feel like i owe it to everyone to point
out that bill maher
is misinformed about every new
technology that he's talked about
finally new rules new rules new rules a
new rule and finally new rule
nothing with crypto in the title ever
turns out good
now if you don't know who he is bill
maher is a comedian
specializing in politics he runs a
successful show on hbo
but he suffers from a chronic case of
smugness now
it takes one to know i'm gonna be honest
with you guys i suffer from an acute
case now and then
but this guy takes it to another level
like he's like every first-time vegan
who becomes insufferable
for a few years while they think that
they're instantly superior to other
humans because they don't eat meat
but bill's like that with like every
topic and usually this is fine because
he's a comedian so he's funny enough to
get away with it but
the chronic smugness becomes a problem
when he talks about things he knows
nothing about which turns out to be a
lot of the time
so before we get into the crypto
comments that bill made and i
do the unthinkable and defend
cryptocurrencies
let's take a look at down memory lane
okay at some of bill's
older takes on new technology to get a
glimpse maybe of where we're going
new rule stop giving me that pop-up ad
for classmates.com
there's a reason you don't talk to
people for 25 years
because you don't particularly like them
besides i already know what the captain
of the football team is doing these days
mowing my lawn
yeah guys who would want to reconnect
with people that they haven't seen in 20
years
couldn't imagine a giant conglomeration
coming out of that
a giant social media organization the
likes of which we've never seen before
surely bill maher is still right about
this one
this social media thing is a thing of
the past never will catch on
yeah bill was one of these uh social
media
skeptical guys who didn't think it would
catch on didn't think people would want
to connect why
connect with your fellow human yeah this
one was a complete disaster but of
course
it gets worse he also thought the camera
phones oh man
how are those gonna catch on i don't
care that your phone takes pictures
it's a phone not a swiss army knife
great now the annoying camera buff and
the annoying cell phone
can merge as one guy
hey if you can figure out how to make
that camera phone
play country western music real loud we
could call it a perfect storm
can you say camera phone and any more of
a condescending way but i gotta admit
look he may he might be right on this
one because many years after
this colossally stupid take posting a
picture
from his camera phone bill maher did
seem to be right
uh that maybe it is the perfect storm
but look maybe you think that i'm just
giving you old examples i can give you
fresh ones too look here's bill's take
on people watching esports you think i'm
out of it because i'm not on twitch well
maybe i get twitch
but i just think people watching other
people play video games
is a waste of time
holy bad take batman i mean this is
ironic coming from a guy
who likes baseball so much that he
bought a stake in the mets
and yeah that's a random cheap shot
against baseball but i mean
you think i'm out of it because i don't
watch baseball
i mean maybe i get watching baseball
but i just think people watching other
people play baseball
is a waste of time wait hold on that
didn't feel right
thank you my studios thank you for the
reassurance
okay it makes my self-esteem a lot
higher now that you guys laugh at me
okay so now that the stage is set
on bill maher's terrible takes on
technology now we can move to crypto
because this is what he said in a recent
segment called cryptocurrency
mania as far as i can tell it's exactly
the same as all the other
cryptocurrencies because the whole thing
is a joke do i need to spell this out
there is something
inherently not credible about creating
hundreds of billions in virtual wealth
with nothing ever actually being
accomplished
and no actual product made or service
rendered
it's like tinkerbell's light its power
source is based solely on enough
children believing in it
hold on there with those relatable
references there boomer now i'm sure a
lot of you guys are going to be
surprised that i'm defending
cryptocurrency in the first place
because after all i've called out the
fact that probably 98
of all cryptos are gonna be going to
zero eventually but it's actually
entirely consistent with my opinion
that that can be true and it also can be
true that he has no idea what he's
talking about
because cryptocurrency is a new
technology and as with most
new technologies early iterations are
going to be clunky
and there are gonna be a ton of scams
but
you can't dismiss the whole underlying
technology
as fake funny money just because you
don't understand it
back in the early internet days many
people thought that the idea of the
internet
was just crazy even late night hosts but
back then
they had the foresight to know that
maybe they didn't know everything
it's easy to criticize something you
don't fully understand which is my
position here go ahead but i can
remember
a couple of months ago there was like a
big breakthrough announcement that on
the internet or on some computer deal
they were going to broadcast a baseball
game you could listen to a baseball game
on your computer
and i just thought to myself does radio
ring a bell
see even though david letterman is
critical he knows and admits that he
doesn't understand the tech
bill maher on the other hand also admits
that he doesn't understand the tech
but that must be because no one else
does either i've read articles about
cryptocurrency i've had it explained to
me and i still don't get it and neither
do you
neither do you like this guy
this guy has the strength of a thousand
karen's he's got enough smugness
to be the president of the pta do you
guys see what i'm talking about
neither do you let's hear that again and
i still don't get it and neither do you
neither do you look i'll admit it bill
has
one real argument against crypto besides
the whole
i don't get it thing that we're all
laughing about here
see his real point boils down to climate
change and cryptocurrencies
effect on it bitcoin uses more energy
than netflix
apple facebook microsoft and google
combined
i mean cars are bad for the climate but
at least they take you somewhere
now here bill actually has a point kind
of bitcoin uses something called proof
of work
to establish consensus which to boil it
down
is a super energy expensive way to
verify transactions
crypto mining has exploded in the last
decade
and electricity use has gone with it and
people are rightfully skeptical
of its long-term environmental impact
but what bill
doesn't understand is that many cryptos
are moving
or have already moved to a different
consensus mechanism
to combat this exact issue it's
something called proof of stake
proof of stake allows you to vastly
lower energy usage
by changing the way you mine now i'm not
going to get too much into this because
enough people have already done the job
and done the research that bill
should have done before doing this video
it's really not the point of this video
the point is is that smart people are
already addressing
this issue which means that this big
monologue moment
at the end where he lectures anyone who
cares about the climate and crypto and
calls them all hypocrites well it means
he's completely wrong about it
tip and progressive and big
environmentalists bullsh
you're money-hungry opportunists and
you're not allowed to pretend you care
about the environment i know
melting ice caps can wait your green new
deal
involves cash social scientists call
this cognitive dissonance a disconnect
between who you think you are
and what you actually do i call it being
foolish
the holier than thou moment really
doesn't land
when you're that wrong about something
it turns out maybe we should finish
our monologue here and try to be a
little more accurate but if i could boil
this whole thing
down it really comes down to the fact
that bill maher has a remarkable
myopia when it comes to new technology
he seems to only be able to see it for
what it is
at that exact moment he sees all the
problems of crypto
and labels the whole thing as fake funny
money as a result but what he doesn't
see
is what it could be he's right about the
fact that many current cryptocurrencies
aren't gonna make it
just like the dot-coms many versions of
classmates.com
are gonna come and go but there will be
a
facebook.com of the crypto era and when
that time comes
you're gonna want to invest in it so
that's basically it i hope this has
made sense of the whole kerfuffle around
bill maher
um and his hot cryptocurrency take which
is gonna age like milk
if you enjoyed it smash like and
subscribe bit unusual for us to be
defending you crypto boys but
i listen i know a cheap shot when i see
it so we're gonna defend you guys
and uh thanks for watching and i'll see
you in the next one
i know what you need this ain't what it
seems nothing but a trick trying to sell
me on a dream but
that was where you lost me